there are two really brief classes of
question I want to address the way you
write your answer okay let's have a look
at this one if I gave you a question
like this okay you've seen this question
you know that it's not sort of geared up
for integration or differentiation for
that manner we can do a simple rewriting
of the integrand to make it look nice so
how when we rewrite it X a pair of yep
negative six fantastic so once you got
everything in index form you're
anti-differentiation your integration
brain could just kind of take over right
I've written and a lot of people are
missing this right you want to simplify
and then you think well I'll just not
worry about this because I'm thinking
about algebra not calculus right now but
you haven't done the integration yet so
this is still hanging around until you
do okay
real quick tell me what to do with this
power arm index goes up to negative five
what do you think is the second most
common error in integration when you see
a power like this yeah negative seven
because right it's easy to go backwards
this we then divide by this what is the
most common error the people make an
integration it's forgetting the cost of
integration okay now at this point we're
pretty much done the integration is
finished but your original question had
no negative indices in it and we tend
not to write negative indices we only
did it so we could integrate right so I
would encourage you to tidy this up in
two ways put the negative at the top put
the negative at the top
this really is division right so on your
denominator this should be a 5 and an X
to the 5 plus your constant that you got
left there okay can you hold on for one
more minute do you need to run for
recess okay I'll make this really quick
because it's the same idea okay what if
I gave you this it's kind of sort of the
same issue right how would you rewrite
it X to the 1/2 right so again I haven't
done the integration yet so my integral
sign is still there when you get to your
answer right index goes up divided by a
new index and
speaking you are done but this is weird
and gross isn't it for starters you've
got a fraction on a fraction and then
secondly this is not something we had in
the original question right how would we
rewrite this without any indices in it
what is X - 3 onto X it's actually X
root X that's a bit sneaky that one that
division by 2 on the bottom actually
goes up onto the top and then you're
finished